There we go.
1, 2, 3, go.
If I can't talk
verbally to you--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
--my music can.
Oh, that's dope.
[MUSIC - JAY-Z, "DIRT OFF YOUR
SHOULDER"]
It's all about your energy,
what you put into the record.
(RAPPING)
The beat has to be
infectious first.
(RAPPING)
You gonna learn about
filling, vocals, software.
[SINGS BEAT]
We're gonna talk
about some of my hits.
"Dirt Off Your Shoulder"
is three instruments.
You're going to learn about
how I can take something simple
and make it complex.
You don't need a big old studio
to do what you need to do.
You can do this on
your own if you have
your computer and your mic.
Watch this.
[BEAT PLAYING]
Yeah.
I start from scratch making
a beat with my mouth.
[SINGING TUNE]
Melody.
Beat.
[BEATS]
Cymbals.
Then I can duplicate
it on a drum machine.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This will be the idea.
Use it as a template
and create around it.
Hey.
See, the feeling
is getting there.
Now, I have to go in the booth.
(SINGING)
There's no thought process.
It's all about having fun.
That's dope.
(SINGING)
Stop.
You see what the
feeling made me do?
That's what it should do to you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I want to give all the
knowledge that I can give.
That's what I'm
here on Earth to do.
We have so much available
to us that it's all
in you, in what you want to do.
If you love it that
much, it's gonna happen.
I'm Timbaland, and
this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]